this episode of the wi files is brought
to you by the wi files operation podcast
deep Dives and longer stories every
week there are extraterrestrials Among
Us they landed 4 billion years ago when
the Earth was just forming and there
weren't humanoids with tall slender
bodies and dark almond-shaped eyes the
aliens were microbes and they were
delivered here and once these aliens
awakened in our mineral Rich World they
multiplied quickly and evolved if you
want to see these aliens for yourself
it's actually pretty easy just look in
the
[Music]
mirror until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are
appreciate sir I'm going to need you to
come with us uh
[Music]
okay hello can can anybody hear me I
don't know why I'm here take off the
pillowcase we are agents with the cfp
cfp I I I don't know what that is I I
never heard of that yeah that's not your
concern uh okay we have been following
your show and we have reason to believe
hey dude I thought I was going to do the
investigation this time do it then do it
stop sitting there do it all right jeez
we have been following your show and we
have reason to believe that you have far
more information
on your topics that you've been sharing
uh what we have been following your show
no no no I I I heard you I just I I just
don't know what that means we have been
following your show he speaks English
you your question is confusing my
question is not confusing it he's just
playing DG you're D I'm well if you know
that I have more information then you
already know that I what I know that you
know just tell us what we want to know
okay what what what episode are you
talking about what what are we talking
about I don't know dude you're you're
the researcher no you're supposed to
know this what the heck the one that has
more information look guys I have a
podcast that covers all of this the
yfiles operation podcast comes out every
week on Mondays we release the YouTube
episodes and then on Wednesdays we do
deep dives into those stories and then
we cover unredacted topics that are a
little too sensitive for
YouTube kind of makes sense and uh where
does this podcast air you can get on
Apple Amazon Spotify Pandora anywhere
you listen to podcasts this sounds
really convenient actually super smart
okay go unlock his cuffs so can I go me
unlock the Cuffs you have the keys No I
gave you the keys you did not
specifically put them under you have
keys give me Keys you're the one who sat
on the syringe start telling
everyone that we were Men In Black and
we're way cooler than in the movies we
are way cooler than the guys in the
movies give me a little support
while down wait wait where did he go a
damn it not
again 4 billion years ago the Earth's
surface was very different than it is
[Music]
today no continents existed the entire
planet was covered in Ocean but the
waters were shallow no more than 100 ft
deep in most areas countless volcanoes
covered the globe spewing molten rock
that would soon form tiny Islands the
atmosphere was a heavy shroud of
volcanic ash superheated dust and toxic
gas this was perfect for the large craft
that had just entered Earth's orbit this
craft was on a
mission on the vessel was a cargo
chamber filled with row after row of
large capsules each about the size of a
car the capsules contain trilli ions of
procariotas are single- celled organisms
they don't even have a nucleus but these
organisms carry something very important
in each and every one of them
DNA there was a loud hiss a door opened
and a capsule was ejected toward the
planet below the vessel powered up its
engines as soon as the payload entered
the atmosphere moments later the ship
bolted out of the solar system and onto
its next destination the alien capsule
glowed red hot as it pushed through the
Earth's atmosphere this wasn't a problem
it was designed for this when the object
hit the water the impact was violent
this was also expected the capsule
opened outpoured what looked like
thousands of glass beads each of these
beads contained millions of organisms
the ocean water dissolved the beads and
released the organisms into the boiling
Seas most died immediately this was also
expected but some
survived
these pioneering organisms thrived in
the depths of the ocean around
hydrothermal vents heated by the Earth's
core the organisms adapted evolved and
diversified this was the
plan and so the tiny planet Earth began
its Journey from a Barren piece of
lifeless Rock to a vibrant Oasis Of
Life the creators knew it would take a
few billion years for intelligent life
to evolve this was all encoded in the D
of those first microorganisms the DNA
was a
program the programmers knew that when
their Creations were finally ready they
decode the program and find a way to
call
[Music]
home there is a growing group of
scientists who believe life on Earth
began from microbes delivered from space
this theory is called panspermia yes
spermia please don't be immature
in Greek pan means all and Sperma means
seed anyway Sante arenus was a major
proponent of this Theory and when it
came to biochemistry he knew what he was
talking about it was 1908 and arenius
was a Nobel prizewinning chemist working
in Sweden the accepted theory of life's
origin is a biogenesis this refers to
the process where chemical reactions of
inorganic material form organic material
which eventually become life and this
happened on Earth about 3.5 billion
years ago arenius wasn't buying it the
ancient Greeks had a much simpler
Theory they suggested the seeds of Life
were present everywhere in the universe
and they were talking about alien
spacecraft dropping probes into
primordial Seas they felt that bits of
space dust contain Seeds of Life the
Greeks and arenus beli that when the
space dust arrived on Earth it brought
life with it then Evolution took over
and created millions of new species of
plants and animals but Life coming from
outer space is tricky even in its most
basic form it shouldn't be able to
survive the harshness of space so arenus
set to find out he created extreme
environments in a lab he subjected
living microorganisms to deadly cold
temperatures near 0 Kelvin if these
microbes were from space they could
handle it cuz nothing else on Earth
could handle zero kin Z Kelvin may not
sound that cold but it is we're talking-
49° F basically the temperature of deep
space the microorganisms could not
survive those temperatures arenius was
disappointed but then he slowly and
carefully applied heat most microbes
remained inert but some when reheated
very carefully activated again they were
alive this shouldn't have happened
the ability to survive Inus 450° cold
was not driven by natural selection in
our terrestrial environment these seemed
to be the abilities developed on another
world arenius had discovered a new kind
of Life which became known as
extremophiles before arenus scientists
didn't believe life could survive in
Earth's most extreme environments but as
soon as they started looking they found
life was
everywhere
arenus had proved that life could
survive the extreme cold of space but
what about extreme heat in 1977
explorers discovered hydrothermal vents
they were on the ocean floor beneath the
galapagus: tectonic plates collide now
humans can't survive very long in
temperatures over about 122° F at that
temperature proteins in our body start
to melt our cells lose their shape at
over
158° our DNA begins to unravel yeah but
nothing loosens up the muscles like a
nice fin rub and a nice hot soak well
maybe but the water released that these
hydrothermal vents is over
800° that would kill you me anything
almost instantly yet here's the thing
that water is teeming with
life there are bacteria thriving in
water at
220° some can even survive in
temperatures higher than that these are
called
hypothermal no one knows how their DNA
keeps its shape at these extremes but it
does and as you go deeper into the ocean
life faces another deadly problem
pressure we don't really notice it but
our atmosphere is heavy enough enough to
exert pressure on us when you go
underwater the weight of the water does
the same thing without protection the
human body can't survive from more than
five or six atmospheres of
pressure but scientists have found
organisms that thrive in 300 atmospheres
pressure doesn't seem to affect the much
at all now how about this there are
organisms that can survive in acid too
pH stands for potential of hydrogen or
power of hydrogen pH ranges from 0 to 14
s is neutral below seven is acid and
above seven is basic or alkaline the
human body likes a pH of seven neutral
or maybe slightly above we go below that
we're in trouble we don't like acid
speak for
yourself the pH scale is logarithmic so
a pH level of six is 10 times more
acidic than neutral a pH level of five
is 100 times more acidic and so on and
so on exposure to acid is very bad for
humans it's bad for almost every living
thing on Earth almost every living
thing there are bacteria that live
happily in sulfuric acid with a pH of
0.3 that is 5 million times more acidic
than human blood even in those extreme
conditions life exists now what about
oxygen before beaming down it's the
first thing you check right can we
breathe out there if there's no Oxygen
the planet's not inhabitable life needs
oxygen but not all life some microbes
called Anor robes convert carbonate
sulfate or iron into energy they don't
need oxygen at all so once scientists
started looking they realized
extremophile microorganisms do more than
exist they're the most numerous life
forms on Earth but if pans spermia is
real these extremophiles would have to
withstand a trip through the harshest
environment we know space and as soon as
we had the technology to get these
things into orbit we
[Music]
did space is an environment more extreme
than anything found on Earth with no
protection from the sun's radiation
temperatures can be over 250° F pass
into the Earth's Shadow hidden from the
Sun suddenly it's minus 148 or lower if
temperature fluctuations don't kill you
radiation will do the trick radi in
space is strong enough to damage human
cells and Destroy DNA molecules unless
you're going to the Moon then for some
reason radiation isn't a problem at all
you're talking about going through the
Van Allen belt yes the Van Allen belt
you know the radiation around the planet
that nobody can get through which is why
nobody went to the
moon the Apollo spacecraft traveled
through the Van Allen radiation belts at
a very high speed and the particles in
the belt are spread very far apart so
the astronauts weren't exposed to much
radi ration ah what are you doing p and
ning now no I'm just
saying even more dangerous than
radiation is the vacuum itself there's
no atmosphere in space and with no
atmospheric pressure the liquids in your
body boil and vaporize saliva tears
blood humans can't survive in space but
there are animals that
can in 2007 the European Space Agency
sent 3,000 living tardigrade into orbit
for 12 days no one expected any to
survive how could they they would have
no shielding from the deadly radiation
or the vacuum tardigrades are a bit more
complex than typical microbes these are
microscopic animals with segmented
bodies and eight legs they're commonly
called water bears now that's a cute
name for what's probably the toughest
animal on earth tardigrades can live at
temperatures ranging from absolute zero
to Boiling they can survive pressure six
times times that of the ocean's deepest
trenches when the orbital Mission
returned 68% of the tardigrades
survived the space vacuum and exposure
to Cosmic radiation were not a problem
for the water bears some even went on to
reproduce Offspring more tolerant to
radiation
exposure lyen is a unique form of life
that represents a symbiotic relationship
between two organisms a fungus and
photosynthetic bacteria other Miss prove
that lyen can also survive in space and
tardigrades by the way are most often
found on Lykan could an asteroid
carrying lyan and tardigrades have
seeded life on Earth well it's been
proven that they could survive the
impact if certain bacterial spores are
shaded from direct sunlight and
radiation as they would be inside a
meteor they can survive in space for
years yeah but for bacteria to be
transported across space it would need
to survive for millions of years and
that seems
unlikely
but in 2020 scientists pulled a piece of
sediment from the ocean floor The Rock
was 20,000 ft down and over 100 million
years old they put it under a microscope
The Rock was full of microbial fossils
they looked more closely those aren't
the fossils of microbes they're actual
microbes 100 milliony old microbes
various types of bacteria
they appeared to be in a type of
suspended animation so the scientists
wondered if they could oh don't tell me
they tried to revive them they tried to
revive them oh no they didn't wake up
did they they woke up no what year was
this 2020 in 2020 eggh heads up pulling
100 million year old bacterias from the
bottom of the ocean and waking them up
hello turn on the news your
morons not only did the bacteria wake up
they had a nice 99.1 success rate and
they started multiplying immediately and
there it is well there were about 100
cells per cubic centimeter at the
beginning of the experiment 68 days
later there were a million cells per
centimeter oh great next thing you know
only'll need two weeks to flatten the
curve not
now okay so this experiment proved that
bacteria can survive dormant for long
enough to travel to other planets that
was shocking but we already knew life
existed on earth 100 million years ago
that doesn't prove it came from outer
space a mainstream science agrees we are
surrounded by creatures that seem alien
in their abilities but the mainstream
view is that life started on Earth from
nothing a biogenesis the earliest
evidence of microbial life dates back to
3.5 billion years at this time the Earth
had oceans of water and plenty of
organic matter this is known as the
primordial soup that soup had all the
ingredients of life uh beef stock and
mira mira carrots onions celery I know
what miraa
is the ingredients were water amino
acids organic gases and some minerals
and that was the prevailing theory for a
long time before 3.5 billion years ago
there was no way the Earth could support
life the conditions were too harsh and
that was the theory for hundreds of
years but then that theory blew up when
they found evidence of life in IR Rock
much
[Music]
older Earth formed a little over 4.5
billion years ago in the hadon Eon named
after Hades the ancient Greek god of
hell because this time in history was
hell on Earth the planet had just
started forming from Interstellar gas
and dust the crust in the atmosphere
didn't exist yet the Earth was so hot
that rocks couldn't solidify this was
not a habitable place so it makes sense
that the first evidence of life was
found in rocks from the second stage of
Earth's geological timeline the archan
Eon this is when the earth began to cool
a crust developed and the oceans formed
the atmosphere was a combination of
methane and ammonia and the sun was only
75% as bright as today but this was good
enough for life to begin we know because
amazingly there are places on Earth
where rocks still exist from that
time one of these places is the isua
greenstone belt in Greenland this strip
of volcanic rocks dates back 3.8 billion
years and geologists have found direct
evidence of Life there microbial
colonies formed about 3.7 billion years
ago fine this proves what scientists
suspected early life began in the
archanon and not before but some of the
oldest rocks on Earth are found in the
Jack Hills and Western Australia
incredibly you can stand on rock formed
in the hadon Eon the time of Hell on
Earth before life even existed however
scientists found something surprising
when they studied ziron crystals from
the
area ziron is unique among all materials
on Earth ziron grows in volcanic rock
and although the crystals are thinner
than a human hair they're nearly
indestructible ziron even outlasts the
rocks in which they're originally formed
researchers have found zircons going
back 4.4 billion years pretty close to
the actual birth of the planet so the
one thing scientists don't expect to
find inside a 4.1 billion year old ziron
crystal is the sign of life except
that's exactly what they found they
found biogenic carbon with isotopic
signatures matching organic
matter the ziron is 4.1 billion years
old this means life had to develop in
the much harsher environment of the
hadon Eon before oceans and a stable
atmosphere formed at the same time
comets and meteors were constantly
raining down on the planet and
panspermia says these meteors were
bringing life with them lots of life and
for years the theory of panspermia that
comets were the source of life was
marginalized it was pseudoscience the
surface of the Earth was too hot it was
molten rock life can't survive that the
conditions that would most likely to
have prevailed near the impact riddled
Earth's surface 4.1 to 4.23 billion
years ago were too hot even for simple
organic molecules to survive let alone
evolve into living complexity this
leaves panspermia as the most plausible
valent option for the origin of
terrestrial life the first microbes were
most likely delivered to the planet
along with impacting comets and
meteorites but even if comets could
somehow land on the earth while it was
forming it wouldn't matter comets are
just dirty snowballs rocks made of ice
and dust may be mixed with ammonia meth
and carbon dioxide there was no way a
comet could contain organic material but
eventually we developed the technology
to send probes to comets and test their
chemical makeup and then all those wacky
pseudoscience pens spermia Believers
well they started looking pretty
smart sir Fred Hoy was an English
astronomer who developed the theory of
Stellar
nucleosynthesis the this Theory says
that all the elements from which our
world is made have been cooked inside
Stars everything from carbon to uranium
atoms were generated eons ago from a
star's power source helium these heavy
elements were then blasted into space in
great Stellar explosions called
Supernova where they later solidified
into planets mountains humans and
everything oil is the man who discovered
we're all made of
Stardust oy was also a believer in the
pens spermia theory he was was convinced
comets had been delivering
microorganisms to Earth since its
formation in 1978 he published the book
life Cloud arguing that comets were the
incubators of life and the stor that
first carried life to earth now this was
considered a fringe idea not accepted by
mainstream science hoy's stubborn
refusal to accept that the origin of
Life happened on Earth and instead was
delivered by comets made him an
intellectual Outlaw in his field but
ignition first stage ignition and
takeoff take off
and in 1986 the European space agency's
jotto mission got a probe within 370 Mi
of Haley's Comet that probe was able to
analyze the chemistry of the Comet it
was made up of mostly water some carbon
monoxide a little bit of ammonia and
meth and this was expected but what was
unexpected was that the comet also
contained hydrogen cyanide a precursor
to amino acids which are necessary to
form
life the jotto mission also detected the
presence of so-called Chan particles CH
n named because they're rich in carbon
hydrogen oxygen and nitrogen this was
more evidence the Comets really were
transporting life's ingredients across
the
Stars space agent gencies worldwide
combined for 12 more missions to examine
comets up close they discovered even
more complex organic molecules such as
ethanol for manide glycol alahh and
acetyl aldhy oy passed away in 2001 but
he lived long enough to review the data
from those space probes he knew he was
on the right track comets delivered the
elements necessary for life if he had
lived just three more years he would
have been amazed in 2004 or for the
first time in history we didn't just
pass by a comet we landed on one and
then the theory of panspermia which
sounds a lot like science fiction
started to sound a lot like science
fact in 2004 the European Space Agency
sent the Rosetta probe to visit Comet
67p and this time it carried a robotic
Lander that explored the comet's surface
the probe spent 786 days in space and
traveled 4.8 billion miles the mission
revealed the comet had primitive water I
formed 4.5 billion years earlier Comet
67p contained a mix of compounds
including ammonium salts ammonium salts
are thought to be one of the precursors
to life they can later form more complex
molecules like amino acids this was an
exciting Discovery but then things got
even more
interesting samples of the Comet were
brought back to Earth and analyzed not
only did they confirm ammonium salts
were present but they also discover the
presence of the amino acid glycine
scientists had officially found a
fundamental building block of life on a
comet and there are thousands of comets
zipping around our solar system and we
now know they contain organic
molecules but thousands of comets
doesn't even begin to describe how many
objects there are out there so
surrounding our solar system is a vast
area called the or
Cloud the or cloud is so large that the
outer edge reaches almost a quarter of
the way to the nearest star it's
staggeringly big and it contains
trillions of objects trillions and these
objects were even more common in the
early solar system when they were busy
delivering water to create Earth's
oceans and delivering the building
blocks of life
itself the more evidence we collect the
more likely hoy's bold theory of
panspermia sounds like the truth but
this is accidental panspermia the more
controversial theory is directed pens
spermia directed pens spermia suggests
that an advanced extraterrestrial
civilization purposely seeded life on
Earth and maybe they did but it seems as
if the aliens had a backup plan in case
their first attempt at seating life on
Earth didn't take so about 540 million
years ago a rock landed on Earth that
contained more than a few microbes The
Rock contained
[Music]
eggs panspermia might not have been a
single event 4 billion years ago large
comets and asteroids only hit the Earth
every few million years but small
meteorites hit the Earth by the
thousands every year we've established
that life has been on Earth for a long
time and there's debate about whether it
began 3 billion years ago ago or 4
billion years ago but there's no debate
that something very strange happened on
Earth 540 million years ago the Cambrian
explosion before the Cambrian Period
life on Earth was microscopic single-
cell organisms like bacteria were the
most common form of life a few very
simple multicellular organisms evolved
but even over a few billion years life
didn't become much more advanced then
suddenly Boom the Cambrian EXP expion
out of nowhere there was a rapid
increase in the diversity and complexity
of life especially in multicellular
organisms this event drastically altered
the course of evolution and shaped the
modern biosphere now there are a few
theories on why Evolution suddenly began
escalating aliens Rising oxygen levels
could have allowed for more complex
metabolisms nope or the end of an Ice
Age could have made the oceans more
survivable
nope but in 2018 a new theory was
proposed a team of 33 researchers
published a paper in a peer-reviewed
scientific journal that was interesting
it was titled cause of the Cambrian
explosion terrestrial or Cosmic 540
million years ago meteors landed
containing biomatter that was more
complex than microbes or amino acids
these meteors had eggs from a new
species Frozen in the icy center of the
rock that species exists to this day and
is different than any other animal found
on Earth the creature has three hearts a
body that can change its shape texture
and color at will it has the brain power
to use tools it can easily navigate
complex mazes now you've seen this
highly adaptable and highly intelligent
alien
species the
octopus an octopus has camera likee eyes
with an iris a circular lens and photo
receptor cells it has half a billion
neurons
more than most other mammals and unlike
other mammals most octopus neurons lie
outside the central brain 2third of its
neurons are in its Arms This results in
the arms being able to act like
independent animals each arm is capable
of touch and taste they can move
separately and can grasp objects even
after being severed from the main body
and if an octopus arm is severed no
problem it grows a new one in its place
completely indistinct isable from the
first these characteristics the large
non-centralized Brain the ability to
camouflage itself and the flexible
bodies appeared suddenly on The
evolutionary timeline and when
scientists examined the genes of the
octopus the true alien nature revealed
itself the octopus genome shows
staggering complexity it has 33,000
protein coding genes that's 10,000 more
than humans now the octopus is said to
have evolved from nautiloids like clams
and oysters but those are nothing like
the octopus at all this mysterious leap
can only be explained by aliens yep
extraterrestrial
intervention exchanges of rock between
planets in our own solar system like
Earth and Mars is a fact and quite
common we' found Mars rocks here and
it's safe to assume there are Earth
rocks on Mars If by bi matter hitched a
ride on those rocks and the conditions
were right life would evolve Mars was
once very earthlike with a stable
climate and lots of surface water if
microbes evolv there they very well
could have ended up here in 1996 a
meteorite from Mars was examined under a
microscope it appeared to contain
fossilized microbes it's a controversial
claim but with what we now know about
comets Life on Mars seems very
plausible
today Rock
841 speaks to us across all those
billions of years and millions of miles
it speaks of the possibility of life if
this discovery is confirmed it will
surely be one of the most stunning
insights into our universe that science
has ever
uncovered its implications are as
far-reaching and all inspiring as Can Be
Imagined what no Clinton joke oh no no
no no no I would never joke about the
clintons yeah but when we're off camera
you joke about the clintons all the time
I never joke about the clintons ever uh
you've made quite a few ah can we move
on please fine if life evolved in our
solar system then chances are it's going
to be found everywhere where the
conditions exist to support it Mars has
water ice and once had a vast ocean just
like Earth Europa one of Jupiter's moons
has liquid ocean under its icy shell
Jupiter's gravity causes tidal forces on
Europa that create heat Enceladus a moon
of Saturn also has a subsurface ocean
plumes of water vapor and ice particles
including organic compounds have been
detected erupting from cracks in the
moon surface Titan another of Saturn's
moons has a dense atmosphere and stable
liquid on the surface now it's liquid
methane not water but life could evolve
there recent studies show Venus could
support microbial life in the upper
layers of its atmosphere spere and
series a dwarf planet in the asteroid
belt has water ice and there's evidence
of liquid salt water below the surface
and these are places right here in our
solar system but if we look further out
the chances of Life increase
tremendously the number of potential
earthlike planets in our galaxy is about
100 billion and there are about 100
billion other galaxies out there so the
total number of planets that could
support life is incomprehensible and
with all the comets and asteroids flying
around our galaxy carrying the seeds of
life panspermia doesn't sound like
pseudoscience in fact life being
delivered here via panspermia is the
only Theory to me that makes
sense life not arising on Earth but
arriving on Earth it's a fascinating
Theory but is it true well a couple of
factors make seaing life on earth a
challenge the time required for
biologically active rocks to be ejected
from a solar system is probably the
biggest obstacle it could take between 4
and 50 million years for rocks to break
from a planet and lead the solar system
but if a planet is hit with a big enough
object like the asteroid that killed the
dinosaurs it can throw rock into orbit
in an instant in the early solar system
giant impacts like this were happening
all the time on every planet but life
finding its way here from another star
that's a long shot not impossible but
very difficult but life finding its way
here from Mars or Venus that's no
problem at all another issue though no
matter the distance traveled the
biological matter has to stay viable for
the journey for millions or billions of
years and the size of the rock really
matters we know that bacteria and even
more complex forms of life can stay
dormant for many years but that doesn't
do you any good if your rock vaporizes
when hitting the Earth's atmosphere
you're going to need a pretty big rock
to get through again not impossible but
not easy unless you adopt the theory of
direct pens spermia which answers all
these concerns the discovery of the
structure of DNA is credited to James
Watson and Francis Crick so reputable
and respected scientists in 1971 they
spoke at a conference on communication
with extraterrestrial intelligence
organized by Carl
Sean they claimed organisms were
deliberately transmitted directly to the
Earth by intelligent beings from another
planet no Randomness was involved the
seeds of Life made it here because this
is where they were sent simple enough
but in the end panspermia means that
we're not from here and you think like
the octopus there'd be evidence within
us that maybe the Earth isn't our
original home well Francis Crick
actually suggested there is evidence in
1973 he published the paper with les
oril a molecular biologist the paper was
called directed pens spermia the paper
says that the chemical composition of
living organisms and I quote must
reflect to some extent the composition
of the environment in which they evolved
the paper makes the point that human
beings have a trace element in their
bodies called meibum which is crucial to
organic processes but here's the thing
mipam is pretty rare on Earth but you
know what's a great source of it
meteorites so maybe maybe somewhere out
there is our home planet where meibum is
plentiful and the fact that we can
survive on earth makes us another
extremophile the idea that the Earth was
seated with life makes more sense to me
than life spontaneously emerging from
organic compounds in a primordial soup I
like the idea of a galaxy teaming with
life I like believing that we're not the
children of the Earth but the children
of the universe but whether life started
here or somewhere far far away it did
start somewhere so my question is who
started
it thank you so much for hanging out
with me today my name is AJ that's eckle
fish I have no jokes about the clintons
this has been the wi files if you had
fun or learned anything do him a favor
subscribe comment like share all those
buttons really help him out and like
most topics we cover on the channel
today's was recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the y files.com
tips and remember the yfiles is also a
podcast twice a week I post deep dives
into the stories we cover here on the
channel I also post episodes that
wouldn't be allowed on the channel those
are called unredacted the podcast is
called the wi files operation podcast
and it's available everywhere you get
your podcasts now if you need more wi
files in your life and not everybody
does really not everybody does but if
you do check out our Discord there are
thousands of people on there I think
there's 40,000 people on there right now
they're there 24/7 and they're into the
same weird stuff we are it's a great
Community it's a lot of fun and it's
free to join now if you want to know
what's going on with the yfiles you can
check out our production calendar it's
at the wi files.com cow that's where we
post our episode schedule upcoming
podcasts live streams pretty much
everything that we're doing is posted
there and special thanks to our patrons
who make the wi files possible every
episode is dedicated to you and I could
not do this without you so from my heart
thank you and if you'd like to support
the channel consider becoming a member
on patreon for as little as three bucks
a month you get access to perks like
videos early with no commercials you get
access to merch only available to
Members Plus you get two private live
streams every week just for you my
camera's on you get to meet the whole
team you put your camera on we get to
see what you look like you don't mind
showing us that it's anyway it's a lot
of fun and it's available to members
another great way to support the channel
is grab something from the wif store
I'll grab a Heckle fish t-shirt or a
fisal coffee mug filled with some coffee
or a beverage of your choice or play Go
Heckle fish cards while you're squeezing
on one of these squeezy stuffed animal
heck ofish squeez and talking fish toys
and those are the plugs until next time
be safe be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh oh oh
yeah I played Bia inara 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I
should but then another conspiracy
theory becomes the truth my friend end
and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with MK truck I'll being
only true
aware D Stanley CU brick fake the moon
landing alone on a film set where the
shadow oh
there throughout well aliens gets Fought
The Smiling man I'm
told and his name was cold and I can't
believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish on thday
night through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth the all through the
[Music]
night the MTH man Sid and the solar
storm still come to have got the the
secret City
Underground Mr serious number stations
planet to project State and where the
dark Watchers
found in a simulation don't you worry
though the black KN satellited to me so
I can't believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish on Thursday nights wed
J to the
night
all I ever wanted was to just hear the
truth so the one all through the
night fish on Thursday night wedn they
J through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so one time repeat all through
the
good love
to good love
to good
dance loves to
dancee loves to dance on the dance
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is right on W
in time Good
Love Good Love
[Music]
oh